hey hey you how are you I haven't seen
you in a minute welcome back to the
monitor as always I am Peter Rubin
senior editor at Wired and this week we
are going to talk about the new novel
from one of my favorite fiction writers
working today we are going to talk about
not one but two video games that will
scratch that itch for cartoonish fun but
first we are going to talk about a movie
that's out on demand this week though is
not hitting theaters until October and
that movie is three two one Frankie goes
boom it's not just something I'm saying
that is the actual title of the movie
that is not out in theaters until
October but is available this week on a
video on demand and on iTunes for rental
only it stars Charlie Hunnam who I spoke
about on last week's segment about sons
of anarchy Charlie Hunnam and chris
o'dowd who you might know he's having a
good couple of years he was the good guy
cop on bridesmaids or in bridesmaids and
he had a small role on HBO series girls
this earlier this year Chris O'Dowd and
Charlie Hunnam are brothers who have a
kind of long and abusive prank field
past Chris O'Dowd supposedly has mended
his ways but then he ends up taping
Charlie Hunnam in a delicate and
compromising position with one of my
favorite female comedy actors working
today Lizzy Caplan and so the movie kind
of unfolds from there it is ridiculous
and it is completely over the top and it
is a lot of fun and it also features
other sons of anarchy cast member ron
perlman playing not the president of a
biker gang but a post-operative
transsexual which you if you are not yet
convinced that you want to see this
movie that I tell you is worth the price
of admission and by price of admission I
made rental and or download costs so
that is out this week see it now before
you have to go fight your way through a
line at the theater or be disappointed
because of theater in your areas of
playing it just see it now it's easier
it's calm it's the humane thing to do
really but now let's talk about let's
talk about a novel because we are
erudite and illiterate here at the
monitor and let's go to a man on the
scene where the novel takes place okay
thank you you know let's talk about
books because reading
so fundamental and let's talk about
literary fiction and let's actually talk
about Telegraph Avenue which is not only
the street in Oakland that I'm standing
on right now but is the title of Michael
che bonds newest novel and it is out
this week Michael che vaughn who you may
know from Wonder Boys or The Amazing
Adventures of Kavalier and clay or the
yiddish policemen's union is one of my
favorite novelists writing today and
this is his newest book it takes place
yes in Oakland it all is centered in the
year two thousand four but there's a
real feel of earlier times in Oakland
that lead up to this through the 70s and
80s and 90s it is the story nominally
superficially of a couple of men who are
friends and work at a record store
together and that mom and pop shop is
kind of being threatened by a larger
company that wants to come in and buy it
up and then those men's wives also kind
of have a business together and our
friends in their own right and that is
the jumping-off point for one of those
meandering interpersonal really chock
full of character and interaction and
wonderful interpersonal insight that
shape on does oh so well it's kind of
not unlike the Oakland version of
jonathan lis thumbs fortress of solitude
those set in a different time period
which is one of my favorite books of the
past 10-15 years and I can't recommend
Telegraph Avenue wholeheartedly enough
even though I am still not quite
finished but it's out this week
hardcover and or kindle or nook or
whatever you are reader of choice maybe
but monitor is not just comic books
people we're trying to broaden your mind
back to you okay thank you for that now
now let's shift our attention from the
world's oldest form of entertainment or
i guess the world's second oldest form
of entertainment to one of the world's
newest forms of entertainment video
games specifically Joe danger to the
movie now Joe Danger the original joe
danger and joe danger special edition
came out in i believe 2010 and 2011
respectively for the ps3 and the xbox
360 respectively but now the racing
platform me thing is back with an all
new game
hello games this time around rather than
just being a motorcycle driving stunt
man who has to navigate obstacle course
after obstacle course you as the titular
joe danger stuntman I have become a
stuntman on a huge action review so the
story mode is actually built of scenes
that you have to play through so it's
not just motorcycles you are also on
skis you also on a unicycle you are also
there's monster truck we're doing with
with creatures and dinosaurs and it is
huge I'm not finished with the game yet
hello games claims that it takes about
20 hours to 100% everything with all the
unlocks in the game and all the
challenges that you can't do on your
first playthrough you have to kind of
get better and get more power-ups and
then go back to the earlier levels and
do them again there is a ton to do here
and i love the original joe danger and
the joe danger special edition i
actually played both of them i'm really
happy that there is a full sequel out
and well worth your time well worth your
download for Xbox 360 users that is out
this week so enjoy it but that's it for
the monitor this week we will be back
next week but until then please email us
at the monitor at wired.com with
suggestions love criticism whatever you
see fit to share with us until then
inspirational catchphrase here